الولايات المتحده تتصدر قائمه الدول
المصدره للاسلحه على مستوى العالم
والمبيعات العسكريه الروسيه تتراجع بسبب
الحرب في اوكرانيا اما فرنسا فتعزز
مكانتها وكوريا الجنوبيه تحقق قفزه هائله
في مبيعاتها العسكريه هذه الملفات وغيرها
نطرحها معكم في حلقه اليوم اهلا بكم في
عسكري تريا
استراليا تستعد لاستبدال طائراتها من طراز
تايجر التي تنتجها شركه ايرباص بطائرات
اباتشي من تراس اي اتش 64 اي الصفقه شملت
29 طائره من فراس افاتشي وبلغت قيمتها نحو
4 مليارات ونصف المليار دولار ومن المقرر
ان تبدا في استلامها بحلول عام 2025 بهذا
تكون استراليا هي المشغل التاسع عشر
لطائرات افاتشي حول العالم حيث تتميز
مروحيات الاباتشي بانخفاض التكلفه
التشغيليه كما انها ايضا تعد خيارا اكثر
فتكا واقل خطوره على المشغل مقارنه
بطائرات تايجر هذا وكانت شركه قد اعلنت من
جانبها عن ان الصفقه ضمن عقد يشمل انتاج
184 طائره للجيش الامريكي وكذلك لدول
حليفه حيث سيحصل الجيش الامريكي على 130
طائره بينما تتقاسم مصر واستراليا الاربع
وخمسين طائره المتبقيه
اعلنت القوات الجويه الامريكيه عن تاجيل
تسيير اول رحله لاحدث قذفت قنابل في
الاسطول الجويه الامريكي
والتي تنتجها شركه نورثروب بروما التاجيل
سيكون لبضعه اشهر عن الموعد المتفق عليه
مع الشركه لكن الاخيره اكدت ان القاذف
ستحلق خلال هذا العام من دون تحديد موعد
نهائي يذكر انه قد تم الكشف عن قاذفه
الاولى في ديسمبر من العام الماضي بعد نحو
ثلاثه عقود من العمل على تطويرها
البنتاجون يعتبر هذه القذفه بمثابه المكمل
للثالوث النووي الامريكي والذي يشمل
صواريخ باليسيه تطلق من الصوامع وكذلك
غواصات تطلق رؤوسا حربيا
[موسيقى]
كوريا الجنوبيه تعزز قدراتها الدفاعيه
بالمزيد من مقاتلات اف 35 الشبحيه هذه
المقاتلات التي تصنعها شركه لوكيد مارتن
الامريكيه في خطه بلغت قيمتها مليارين و
850 مليون دولار على ان يتم تسليم هذه
الطائرات بحلول عام 2023 كوريا الجنوبيه
التي لم تعلن عن عدد هذه الطائرات لديها
بالفعل موافقه من الخارجيه الامريكيه على
شراء 20 طائره اخرى بخلاف اربعين طائره
تخدم بالفعل لدى الجيش الكوري الجنوبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التقرير الاخير لمعهد استوكهولم الدوليه
لابحاث السلام والمعروف باسم سيبري كشف عن
تراجع الانفاق العالميه على التسلح في
الفتره ما بين 2018 و2022 مقارنه بالسنوات
الخمس السابقه كما كشف ايضا عن زياده
بنسبه 74% في واردات السلاح الى اوروبا
وبينما تصدرت الولايات المتحده قائمه
الدول المصدره للاسلحه على مستوى العالم
جاءت روسيا في المرتبه الثانيه هذا رغم
التراجع الذي حدث لصادراتها العسكريه فيما
تحاول فرنسا تعزيز مكانتها بين الدول
المصدره للاسلحه ونجحت بالفعل في تقليص
الفارق بينها وبين روسيا لمناقشه اهم ما
كشفوا تقرير المعهد الدولي لابحاث السلام
عن سادرات وكذلك واردات الاسلحه حول
العالم وايضا توجهات الدول في الانفاق
الدفاعيه انضموا الينا من الباحث الاول في
برنامج انتقال الاسلحه في معهد سيبري
السيد
اولا مصر ويزمان اهلا بك معنا في عسكري
تيريا يعني برغم الحرب في اوكرانيا احتفظت
روسيا بمكانتها هي الدوله الثانيه على
مستوى العالم في مجال تصير الاسلحه هل هذا
يعني بان سمعه السلاح الروسي لم تتاثر حتى
هذه اللحظه بسبب الحرب والى اي مدى تعتقد
بانه سيكون هناك تاثير سواء ايجابي او
سلبي على سمعه السلاح الروسي في المستقبل
سمعتهم لم تعد كما كانت والارقام الموجوده
في الدراسه مبنيه على مده خمس سنوات لكن
ان نظرنا للسنوات الثلاث الماضيه التي تلت
فتره السنوات الخمس تجد ان صادرات السلاح
الروسي اقل بكثير اذ تعاني روسيا العديد
من المشكلات فيما يتعلق بتصدير السلاح
حاليا كما ان هناك عقوبات مفروضه عليها من
دول الغرب ما يجعل انتاج السلاح اكثر
صعوبه على روسيا كما يتعرض المشترون
المحتملون والحاليون للسلاح الروسي لضغط
لعدم الشراء وهذا الضغط من الاوروبيين
وكذلك امريكا ناهيك عن الحرب نفسها
والدروس المستفاده من هذه الحرب وهي ان
السلاح الروسيه لا يبدو على درجه جيده من
الكفاءه كما ان صناعه السلاح في روسيا
مشغوله حاليا لانتاج السلاح لاستخدامها
الخاص ما يترك صناعه السلاح للتصدير تفتقر
للوقت وفي السنه المقبله المشهد تراجعا
اضافيا على صادرات السلاح الروسي مصر
نجحت يعني طبقا للتقرير في معهد استقال
الى انها تقلص الفارق ما بينها وبين روسيا
وتحاول ان تصل الى المرتبه الثانيه في
قائمه الدول المصدره هل تعتقد بانه فرنسا
ستنجح في هذا الامر وما هو الانعكاس
الاستراتيجي لهذا الامر سواء بالنسبه
لفرنسا او بالنسبه لاوروبا
حققت فرنسا نجاحات ملحوظه في السنوات
الاخيره خاصه في بيع طائراتها المقاتله
التي لم يكن عليها طلب في السابق وفي
الوقت ذاته تتراجع مبيعات روسيا وبالتالي
ستتساويان قريبا وكما نعلم من طلبات
الشراء الحاليه نجد ان فرنسا لديها طلبات
تفوق بكثير الطلبات من روسيا لذلك اتوقع
ان فرنسا ستتجاوز روسيا خلال نحو ثلاث
سنوات لتصبح ثاني اكبر دوله مصدره للسلاح
اي تتقدم فرنسا وتتراجع روسيا
يعني التقرير كشف كذلك عن تراجع في مبيعات
الاسلحه الصينيه وايضا البريطانيه في حين
انه كشف عن قفز هائله في مبيعات كوريا
الجنوبيه وكذلك الايطاليه اولا ما هي
اسباب تراجع المبيعات الصينيه وكذلك
البريطانيه وما هي اسباب ارتفاع مبيعات
الاسلحه سواء من كوريا الجنوبيه او من
ايطاليا على الجانب الاخر يعني
بعض هذه الانماط تحدث بالصدفه خاصه
بالنسبه للدول غير المصنفه على قائمه اكبر
مصدري السلاح كوريا الجنوبيه مثيره
للاهتمام هنا لانها تمكنت خلال العقود
الثلاثه الماضيه من تطوير صناعه السلاح
لتكون قادره على التصميم والانتاج وروجت
كوريا لذلك وتمكنت من تحقيق نجاح مبهر ليس
فقط في الدول الناميه التي كانت تستهدفها
في البدايه بل ايضا في دول متقدمه ومؤخرا
في عام 2022
تلقت كوريا طلبا ضخما من بولندا ما يشير
الى ان كوريا الجنوبيه ستواصل تطورها
كدوله مصدره للسلاح فمنتجات كوريا متقدمه
الى حد كبير ولديها الرغبه في التصدير
وتقديم الدعم للصادرات من خلال البيع
بالائتمان ومن الواضح ان الحكومه وراء هذا
القطع وليس لديها اي شيء ضده بل تدعمه
بشكل كامل وهناك اسواق كثيره اداء كوريا
فيها ممتاز لان السعر معقول وسجل من حيث
الدعم الفني مهم جدا وقوي وهذا مبني الى
حد كبير على نجاح كوريا في القطاع المدني
اذ تتميز المنتجات المدنيه الكوريه
بجودتها والدعم الفني لها جيد وهذا ينطبق
ايضا على السلاح
مصر سجلت المرتبه الثالثه في مشتريات
الاسلحه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط طبقا
للتقرير لكن لمن كانت الحصه الاكبر هل
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ام لروسيا
وكذلك ما هو ما هي توقعاتكم بالنسبه
لمشتريات وتوجه الانفاق العسكري في مصر
خلال السنوات القادمه
[موسيقى]
في السنوات الاخيره روسيا وفرنسا كانت من
اهم موردي السلاح لمصر وواصلت امريكا
مكانتها كما لدينا ايطاليا التي حصلت على
طلبات كبيره وكذلك المانيا اما كيف سيكون
الوضع في المستقبل القريب حسب ما ارى
ستكون روسيا خارج هذه الدائره فقد كانت
هناك صفقه لشراء طائره روسيه المقاتله لكن
الصفقه تم الغاءها العام الماضي والسبب هو
الضغط الامريكي على مصر كي لا تمضي بهذه
الصفقه والا فسيكون لذلك تبعات هذه
الطائره ذاتها يتم بيعها حاليا لايران لكن
هناك دول اخرى ظهرت ولديها الرغبه بتزويد
مصر بالسلاح ومصر لديها الرغبه بالشراء
منهم كوريا الجنوبيه وقعت صفقه كبيره مع
مصر لذا ارى اننا سنشهد زياده في الدوري
الكوري في السنوات المقبله كما توجد طلبات
من فرنسا ومصر لا تزال تبحث عن اسلحه اخرى
من متنوعه مثل الاوروبيين وكوريا وربما
تركيا وبالتاكيد من امريكا لان ما تحصل
عليه مصر من امريكا هو بتمويل امريكي عبر
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه وهذا امر
مفيد في كل الاحوال مصر على خلاف كل
التوقعات شهدت منطقه الشرق الاوسط تراجع
في الانفاق الدفاعي اولا برايك ما هي
اسباب هذا التراجع وهل هذا الامر له علاقه
بمساله اهتمام دول او بعض دول المنطقه
بتوطين الصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه وكذلك
كيف تقيم اصلا تجربه بعض دول الشرق الاوسط
في توطين الصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه
بداخلها
[موسيقى]
بالتاكيد توطين
العسكري هدف
للسلاح ليس في العالم العربي فحسب بل في
مناطق اخرى ايضا لكن لم تكن ناجحه بشكل
حقيقي في العالم العربي حتى وقت قريب اذ
بدانا نرى دولا مثل الامارات تدخل في
تصنيع سلاحها الوطني وتصميمه بمساعده من
الخارج وبعناصر مستورده لكنها في النهايه
تصميم اماراتي السعوديه كذلك اطلقت
برنامجا للانتاج والتصميم محليا مصر ايضا
تعود الى هذا المسار هناك الكثير من
التحرك في هذا المجال لكن الى اي مدى يمكن
لهذه التجارب ان تنجح هذا امر يصعب ان
نعرفه السلاح البسيط وحتى الضخم منه لا
يصعب انتاجه لكن عندما ياتي الامر للسلاح
الاكثر كلفه والاكثر تقدما وقوه ستواجه
الدول مشكله وجود التكنولوجيا ووجود
اقتصاد قوي ليغطي التكاليف وهذا يحتاج
وقتا كثيرا كما نرى على سبيل المثال في
دول مثل الهند التي غير قادره على اداره
الانتاج رغم مرور 50 عاما مصر وزمان الحرب
في اوكرانيا لها تداعيات كبيره على
مشتريات السلاح في الوقت الحالي في القاره
الاوروبيه لكن ما هي اكثر المنظومات التي
يوجد عليها اقبال حاليا من قبل دول القاره
الاوروبيه وكذلك الى اي مدى الشركات سواء
في اوروبا او في الولايات المتحده قادره
على تلبيه هذا الكم المتنامي من الطلب
اعتقد اننا على المدى البعيد الى حد ما
ستكون هناك قدره على تلبيه الطلب لكن
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وانهم يحتاجون السلاح
اليوم وليس غدا هنا تكون المساله صعبه لان
خطوط الانتاج محدوده فلننظر الى امور
بسيطه مثل الذخيره حيث تستنفذ اوكرانيا
الالاف منها يوميا وتعداد استهلاكها
السنوي بالملايين خطوط الانتاج في امريكا
واوروبا ليست مصممه حاليا لانتاج هذه
الكميات في وقت قصير سيكونون مستعدين خلال
عام او اثنين فالمساله لا تتعلق بالتصميم
بل اقامه مصانع جديده وهذه ليست اكبر
مشكلاته
عند
البحث الاول في معهد الدولي لابحاث السلام
في برنامج انتقال الاسلحه السيد شكرا
جزيلا على وجودك معنا
[تصفيق]
التغيرات الميدانيه المرتبطه بالشتاء
القارص دفعت القوات الروسيه لادخال منظومه
دفاع جوي متنقله هذا بهدف حمايه قواتها من
الاستهداف سواء عبر طائرات حربيه او حتى
عبر مسيرات والاهم ان تكون لديها قدره على
العمل في ظروف مناخيه قاسيه وتضاريس صعبه
منظومه تور ام تو دي تي منظومه طور هي
منظومه دفاع جوي تم تجهيزها باحدث طراز
لصواريخ تورا والمعروفه لدى حلف الناتو
سام خمسه عشر هذه المنظومه هي منظومه
قصيره المدى يمكنها التصدي لطائرات وكذلك
المسيرات وايضا التهديدات الصاروخيه كما
انه لديها الامكانيه لكشف هذه التهديدات
والتعامل معها اثناء الحركه هذه المنظومه
تتكون من رادار لرصد الاهداف واخر لتوجيه
الصاروخ واطلاقه بالاضافه الى 16 صاروخا
تطلق بشكل عمودي تتكون بطاريه صواريخ طور
من اربع منصات لاطلاق وتوجيه الصواريخ
وايضا عربه قياده وسيطره هذه المنظومه
لديها القدره على التعامل مع 48 هدفا في
وقت واحد بمدى يصل الى 12 كيلومتر وعلى
ارتفاع يصل حتى عشره كيلو مترات وفق
تقارير صحفيه قامت روسيا بنشر هذه
المنظومه في شهر ديسمبر من العام الماضي
في اوكرانيا لكن وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
نشرت مؤخرا مقطع فيديو يظهر احتراق هذه
المنظومه بعد استهدافها بقذيفه قامت
باطلاقها قوات اوكرانيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل السعوديه تتعاون مع عملاق
الصناعات الدفاعيه الامريكي لتوطين
الصناعه المسيرات
اهلا بكم من جديد شركه
الامريكيه هي واحده من كبرى الشركات
المختصه بالمنظومات الدفاعيه الطائره
وتحديدا المنظومات المسيره مؤخرا وقعت هذه
الشركه اتفاق تعاون مع شركه سرب السعوديه
لتطوير مسيره ابقيق ابقيق هي مسيره تم
تصنيعها بالكامل محليا وبحقوق ملكيه فكريه
سعوديه خالصه
التطور الكبير والحيوي في مجال الطائرات
المسيره جعل الكثير من الدول تسعى لتعزيز
قدراتها في هذا المشاكل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مؤخرا باتت تبدي اهتماما كبيرا
بتطوير هذا المجال سواء عبر شركات محليه
او حتى عبر اتفاقيات وشركات مع شركات
دوليه كبرى عامله في هذا المجال مؤخرا
قامت بتوقيع اتفاقيه مع شركه
وهي احدى الشركات التي تم دمجها ايضا مع
شركه ريسون الامريكيه حول هذه الاتفاقيه
وكذلك ما هي القيمه المضافه التي تشكلها
هذه الاتفاقيه بالنسبه للسعوديه وكذلك
بالنسبه للشركه معنا السيد كولين ماهولي
رئيس قسم التطوير الاعمال والشركات
الاستراتيجيه بشركه
مؤخرا وقعتم مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اتفاقيه شراكه بشان تطوير طائرات مسيره ما
هي القيمه المضافه التي سيشكلها او
ستشكلها هذه الاتفاقيه بالنسبه للسعوديه
وكذلك ما هي التكنولوجيا التي من ممكن ان
يتم نقلها للسعوديه في هذا المجال
نحن فخورون جدا لتوقيع اتفاق مع شركه
السرب والعمل الذي يقومون به على
المنظومات الجويه غير الماهوله في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انه في الحقيقه مزيج بين
الاستراتيجيه طويله الامد للشراكه من اجل
تطوير القدرات الجديده فعبر هذه الشراكه
سنعمل على تحقيق التكامل مع منظومه
للاستشعار كما سنعمل على منظومه الطيار
الالي بيكولو ووصلت البيانات اللاسلكيه اس
سي اي اس ار لهذه المنصه فجوهر هذه الجهود
هو العمل مع شركاء والشركات في دول الشرق
الاوسط مصر
بمناسبه الشرق الاوسط كما ذكرت ما هي
خطتكم في الشرق الاوسط خلال المرحله
القادمه خاصه بان هناك الان الكثير من
الدول في هذه المنطقه لا تتسعى لتوطين
الصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه بداخلها والى
اي مدى لديكم يعني ترحيب بمساله توطين
التكنولوجيا او نقل المعرفه ونقل الافكار
لهذه الدول
بمواطن
نحن نعمل في هذه المنطقه منذ عده عقود
واساس هذا النجاح هو اسلوب شراكاتنا مع
الصناعه لتحقيق رؤى الدول المتعدده مثال
على ذلك حاليا هو فضاء القتال ذي
الاتصالات متعدده النطاقات لان معاركنا
المستقبليه يجب ان تكون مرتبطه بشكل مباشر
بالمعلومات الانيه فمع توسعنا في المنطقه
نسعى لتنميه تجاربنا لكي نزود هذه القدرات
لاحتياجات المعارك المستقبليه
وعدتم في كولينز بتخفيض الانبعاثات
الكربونيه لطائرات المدنيه بحلول عام 2050
لمستوى الصفر لكن ماذا عن الطائرات
الحربيه وكذلك هل سيؤثر هذا على خطتكم في
الانتاج داخل الشركه ام لا اوكي
هذا هو عام الاستدامه في الامارات العربيه
المتحده وشركه كولينز متحمسه جدا للمساهمه
عبر جميع امكاناتها في تخفيض الانبعاثات
الكربونيه من الطائرات الى مستوى الصفر
فاذا ما تحدثنا عن قدرات الالكترونيات
للتحليق بفعاليه من النقطه الف الى النقطه
باء او قدرات هيكل الطائره لتخفيض وزنها
او حتى تنويع مصادر طاقه الطائره مثل
الهجين الكهربائي وصولا الى استخدام
الهيدروجين ووقود الطيران المستدام فكل
هذه الامور تساعد الطيران التجاريه
والعسكريه لخفض اثرها على البيئه
مستر كولين
كانت واحده من الشركات المهمه في مجال
الالكترونيات والطيران على مستوى العالم
مؤخرا تم دمج الشركه مع شركه ريت يون شركه
بالتاكيد هي شركه كبيره لكن هناك تحذيرات
دائمه من عمليه الاستحواذ او الدمج ما بين
الشركات الصغيره والشركات الكبيره وان
هناك مخاوف يؤثر هذا الامر على الصناعات
الدفاعيه على مستوى العالم انتم
فيس كيف تاثرتم بهذا الدمج وهل شكل لكم
قيمه مضافه ام لا
عمرو شركتنا الان ثلاثه اعوام منذ دمج
شركتي ريثيون تي سي وقد وفر لنا هذا الدمج
امكانيه هائله لاستكشاف جميع منتجاتنا
لجمع قدرات الشركتين بشكل سلس لكي نصل الى
المعادله الشهيره 1 + 1 = اكثر من اثنين
فاذا اخذنا بيئه العمليات متعدده النطاقات
فتشمل اجهزه الاستشعار والتواصل وتفسير
البيانات والعمل ولدينا اجزاء من شركتنا
تتعامل مع كل واحده من هذه المراحل
فالكفاءه الناجمه عن جمع كل ذلك ستكون
مثيره جدا
تطوير الاعمال وشركات الاستراتيجيه بشركه
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا
شهدت حقبه الحرب البارده وتحديدا في فتره
الحرب في فيتنام ظهور طائرات حربيه
امريكيه متعدده احدى هذه الطائرات تم
تصميمها لتكون مقاتله هجوميه اسرع من
الصوت والاهم ان يكون لديها قدره على
توجيه ضربات نوويه الى اي هدف في عمق
الاتحاد السوفيتي المقاتله متعدده المهام
115 تم تصميمها لتحل محل القذفه المقاتله
اف 84 اف كما انها دخلت الى الخدمه في
سلاح الجو الامريكي في العام
1959 لتكون طائره الهجوم والسيطره الجويه
الاساسيه في حرب فيتنام تم تزويد مقاتله
الاف مئه وخمسه بمدفع رشاش من طراز فولكان
متعدد الفوهات من عيار 20 مليمتر هذا
بالاضافه الى صواريخ المضاده للطائرات
هذه المقاتله كانت لديها قدره على حمل ما
يقرب من سته اطنان من القنابل والصواريخ
بالاضافه الى قدرتها على حمل قنبله نوويه
خضعت هذه الطائره لعدد من التعديلات من
بينها مثلا توسيع قمره القياده لتتسع
لتيارين وكذلك تحويلها الى طائره متخصصه
في استهداف صواريخ السام اثنين كما تم
تسليحها بصواريخ من طراز الشرايك الذي
يتتبع موجات الراديو ويدمر منصات الرادار
التي توجه صواريخ السامه تم انتاج
833 طائره من هذه المقاتله الا اسقاط عدد
كبير منها وكذلك كثره المشكلات الفنيه
التي واجهتها مثلا ارتفاع درجه حراره
المحرك وكذلك تسريبات الوقود كل هذه
الامور دفعت القوات الجويه الامريكيه
لسحبها ولكن بشكل تدريجي حتى خرجت تماما
من الخدمه في عام 1980 هذا بحسب موقع
المتحف الوطني للقوات الجويه
الامريكيه
حلقه عسكريه لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]